hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saludas de un líder y año
[Música]
los refugiados migrantes y solicitantes
de asilo en el mundo comienzan a recibir
dosis de la vacuna contra el kobe 19 sin
embargo aún falta mucho para que todos
sean incluidos en los planes de
inoculación según la agencia de la onu
para los refugiados en 91 países ya
comenzó el proceso para inmunizar a
poblaciones desplazadas para garantizar
un acceso equitativo a los miles que
siguen en la lista de espera hace falta
eliminar barreras que limitan el acceso
para los que huyeron de sus hogares el
idioma la falta de documentos de
identificación y la desinformación
llevan a algunos a quedar fuera del
proceso el llamado es también a los
gobiernos para que aceleren el
despliegue de las campañas de vacunación
estos inmigrantes subsaharianos llegaron
a túnez sin documentos
ahora intentan acceder a una vacuna
contra el cou y 19 pero sin papeles es
difícil entrar a la plataforma para el
registro de vacunación
los más jóvenes deben esperar mientras
los ancianos reciben las primeras dosis
y el refugiado no sabe cómo registrarse
para la vacunación como podrían saberlo
deberían decirles cómo se hace y
preguntar si quieren vacunarse o no
debería haber una campaña de
sensibilización sobre este tema ahora
hay una gran falta de sensibilización y
los esfuerzos de diferentes países para
avanzar en la vacunación de la población
desplazada en el mundo son notables pero
en algunos casos los trámites
administrativos obstaculizan el proceso
y algunos de los requisitos que los
gobiernos han establecido para registros
de la vacuna requieren documentos de
identidad nacionales que los refugiados
y las poblaciones apátridas no tienen
granja por lo que nuestro esfuerzo se
centra en buscar un sistema con los
gobiernos para que acepten utilizar
otros documentos hits inglés y
documentos en el continente africano se
han dado pasos importantes para el
acceso a las vacunas en senegal y
camerún por ejemplo se permitió el
registro de los refugiados en centros de
salud y ayuntamientos cercanos
y en el noroeste de siria avanza la
segunda fase de las campañas de
inoculación para desplazados que me
dijeron que me pusiera la vacuna pero
tenía miedo
luego me preocupé porque podría infectar
me de coronavirus y gracias a dios pude
ver que recibirla fue algo bueno siempre
las vacunas para cubrir la población
desplazada llegaron en medio de un
repunte de los contagios en un país
devastado por la guerra al menos 600 92
personas murieron en estas áreas por
complicaciones relacionadas con el cobo
y 19 son en total 82 4 millones de
desplazados en el mundo que se espera
reciban una dosis
y en canadá la vacuna contra el cob y 19
le da tranquilidad a un grupo de
trabajadores migrantes que llegaron al
país para laborar en el sector agrícola
una plaza en la que ellos son expertos y
necesarios el reclutamiento de
trabajadores temporales extranjeros fue
un trabajo difícil por la pandemia pero
las dosis de la vacuna son una
oportunidad tanto para los migrantes
como para sus empleadores el informe es
de françois y wii
todo bien reacción sólo un poco dolor de
brazo normal
william hernández morales acaba de
llegar de guatemala y de recibir su
primera dosis de la vacuna contra la cob
y 19 por seguridad y por ley tenemos que
guardar cuarentena podemos ayudar y
hablar con nuestros familiares por el
tele por medio del teléfono tienen un
poco de miedo porque todo el riesgo
vuelve en forma parte de un grupo de
alrededor 100 personas que vino a
recolectar chalotes cebollas o lechugas
en esta granja en el sur de quebec una
vez hecha la cuarentena empiezan una
temporada de recorte intensa que dura de
cinco a seis meses la vacuna les da más
tranquilidad estamos más seguros un poco
más protegidos esas dosis nos ayuda
mucho y quizás en nuestro país quizás
nos tarda tener pero aquí en canadá ya
ya tenemos unos compañeros nomás
llegaron al aeropuerto ya tienen la
dosis y trabajar uno más con
tranquilidad
según fuéramos una organización sin
fines de lucro que recluta mano de obra
internacional entre 14 y 15 mil obreros
son reclutados para el programa de
trabajadores agrícolas temporales en
quebec
esta mano de obra es crucial pero el
reclutamiento ha sido más difícil con la
pandemia y el cierre de fronteras
los agricultores tuvieron pérdidas
considerables el año pasado debido a la
pandemia debido a la falta de
trabajadores este año el reto sigue
siendo conseguir trabajadores porque
siempre es una preocupación sin
trabajadores una granja como la nuestra
no puede hacer mucho por faus no según
tú a que el sindicato más importante del
sector agroalimentario privado todavía
falta mejorar mucho en el área de la
salud y seguridad laboral así como el
alojamiento de los trabajadores
temporeros que son muchos cada año
canadá emplea medio millón de ellos
de los 126 países que acogen a más de
500 personas refugiadas en sus
territorios 123 incluyeron a los
desplazados en sus planes de vacunación
o por lo menos ya se comprometieron a
hacerlo y el dato de migración de la
semana la malaria la fatiga psicológica
causada por la pandemia y la
desnutrición aguda fueron las
principales amenazas para la salud y el
bienestar de los refugiados durante 2020
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]